an average of 22 people died in America
every day while waiting for organ
transplants a group of researchers
affiliated with Harvard University and
also a private company hope to
eventually change that statistic by
using organs from cloned pig cells their
method uses the powerful technology
called CRISPR to edit the DNA of the
animals it removes potentially harmful
viruses from the pigs organs scientists
then clone those edited cells put them
in an egg and implant that egg into a
sow this enables them to ultimately
breed pigs with virus free organs our
dr. David agus is in Los Angeles
good morning this we just went through
the process here what does this
ultimately mean though for humans it's
absolutely wild I mean literally
considered science fiction several years
ago now with this enzyme CRISPR that
cancer with surgical precision change
one of the letters of the DNA code they
can eliminate several dozen viruses that
have always been in the pig genome and
in studies done before if you took Pig
cells in human cells and put them
together the viruses would go to the
human cells and so now they've been
eliminated or inactivated so all of a
sudden it opens the door for the
potential of pigs you know pigs organs
are about the same size as human organs
so they're actually perfect for
transplantation
doctor doctors regularly use pig valves
in heart-to-heart surgeries on humans so
I'm just wondering how is this
difference well Jeff pig valves are put
in formaldehyde first and so they're not
live human and the live Pig tissue but
they're put in formaldehyde and they're
fixed and then they're put in and again
that shape of the pig valve is very
similar to ours so they're used for
valve transplantation but these are live
cells functioning organs kidneys livers
hearts it really is going to be dramatic
how it could affect many human lives dr.
agus the ability to edit DNA seems to be
gaining rapidly as the science advances
but there are some legal and ethical
concerns here what are they and do are
they valid well you know vlad last week
did we did the story of you know
changing the human embryo when you
embryo the DNA is past generation to
generation here it's just in the Oregon
but we need some group in charge not
just in the US but internationally to
start to draw boundaries we're talking
about some dramatic advances and
literally happening week by week but
they can keep going and so the challenge
is to do it right the challenge is
someone not to change an embryo to make
them taller stronger faster the
challenge is to do it to benefit human
health in a positive way on a global
sense dr. David agus thank you very much
thank you guys